وسط حاله من الاستغراب والاستنكار احيانا
اخرى بين الاهالي قررت سيده مصريه ترشح
لمنصب عمده قريه نابعه تابعه لمحافظه
المنوفيه منصب ارتبط تاريخيا بالرجال فقط
لكن دكتوره ساره الزهران الاستاذ الجامعي
قررت خوب هذه التجربه في البدايه عرضتها
عائلتها وطلبتها بالتعقل لكنها شرحت لهم
حرصها على تقديم العون لاهالي قريتها ساره
زهران من الحاصله على الدكتوراه في
التخطيط الاجتماعيه والسياسه الاجتماعيه
تعرف جيدا انا السباق على نيل منصب العمده
على كل من المنوفيه تنظم الينا المحاضره
في ماده التدريب الميداني بكليه الخدمه
الاجتماعيه بجامعه حلوان الدكتوره ساره
زهران الدكتوره اهلا بك يسعد صباحك شكرا
على تواجدك معنا دكتور يعني منصب ارتبط
تقليديا وتاريخيا بالرجال انت اول سيده
تترشح لمنصب عمده في المنوفيه حدثنا اولا
كيف جاء هذا القرار ولماذا
اولا صباح الخير عليكم وعلى مصر وعلى
العرب كلهم جميعا يا رب بخير دائما
وبسعاده اولا القرار ده جاء لي من ان انا
يعني اولا السيد الرئيس فخامه السيد
الرئيس دائما عمال ينادي بني الشباب
محتاجين ان احنا ممكن الشباب
يعني في عصر السيد الرئيس اصبح في المراه
قضيه واصبحت وكيلك نيابه دخلت في كل
المجالات اا طبعا انا كان طبعا من كلام
الرئيس جدا عن اهميه اهميه ان احنا كشباب
في بناء الوعي وبناء الجمهوريه الجديده
كان دائما شغل شاغل هو انا دوري ايه يعني
انا اللي يعني دوري في مجتمعي الصغير او
على مستوى الوحده الصغيره اللي انا عايشه
فيها دوري ايه كمان اتفاجات الفتره اللي
فاتت او يعني ايام ما كان لسه مفتوح بقى
بالعبوديه اللي في مشاكل كثيره جدا في
القريه همم يعني اللي هي بغض النظر عن
مشاكل قصور الخدمات ودي اللي موجوده في
جميع الكوره مصر بدرجات متفاوته ولكن لقيت
ان في همم يعني موضوع ثاني مهم جدا وهو
بزواج القاصرات طب دكتوره ساره
هل يتقبل المجتمع ان تكوني ملجا لرجال
المنطقه في ظل الثقافه الذكوريه السائده
والله انا الحمد لله في قريتي بنسبه 90%
همم الحمد لله متقبلين الموقف متقبلين
الموضوع كله همم
بيقولوا لي على بركه الله
سيري على بركه الله احنا وراءنا بنسبه 90%
اما الباقي فهما مش معارضيني انا كشخص هم
معارضني فكره اا انا دلوقتي بحاول ان انا
اا اوعيهم واعرفهم اني منصب العمده حاليا
ما عادش بين الصوره اللي كانت بتبينها
السينما المصريه او اللي كان قبل كده منصب
العمده حاليا همم هو همم يعني همم وظيفه
ايه اداريه ايوه اي نعم هو بيبقى على راس
السلطان تنفيذيه ولكن منصب العمده دلوقت
همم في تحت من ايده او معه يعني على جنب
الى جنب الى جنب تحدث عنك شخص يعني ماذا
قررت التقدم لهذا المنصب قلت انه برنامجك
سيكون خارج او تفكير في خارج الصندوق كيف
دكتوره حدثنا اكثر
اولا انا دارسه تخطيط وسياسه كليه خدمه
اجتماعيه جامعه حلوان دائما قناه الاخصائي
الاجتماعي
فرق في المجتمع من خلال دراستي انا شايفه
ان انا عندي كثير جدا من المشكلات اللي
انا ممكن اتغلب عليها
من خلال استخدام الموارد والامكانيات في
المجتمع سواء كان الشباب او عقولهم او
سواعدنا احنا همم جميعا في القريه فان شاء
الله بامر الله تعالى ناويه ان البرنامج
بتاعي يكون فيه اا يعني فيه جامد قوي
لوظيفه العمده مش بس الجانب الامن او
الجانب الاجتماعي بفضل المنازعات ولكن
يكون في جانب عنوان تنوي مهم جدا يمكن من
خلاله ان انا انهض بقريتي وانهض باهل بلدي
اا يعني من صوره افضل منها
يعني بصراحه هل تعتبرين انه حضورك كبيره
هذه المره لتكون عمده المنوفيه
بصراحه انا عندي ثقه كبيره جدا في القياده
السياسيه وفي القياده الامنيه في المنوفيه
ان هم يدوني الفرصه اني انا اثبت وجهه
نظري واثبت نفسي واقول ان الست تقدر في اي
مجال حتى لو كان مجال يعني بياخذ دور
عليها ان هي تدخل
كافيه دكتوره ساره زهره شكرا جزيلا لك على
وجودك معنا